To understand what parameters I have available to me,
going back to the sklearn documentation.
So this should look kind of familiar.
We found this through Google, remember?
I am going to scroll down a little bit until I find the DecisionTreeClassifier
this being documented here and
I am just going to click on this link.
And, this takes me to the specific page that's about the DecisionTreeClassifier.
And this box right here is what I'm looking for.
This is going to tell me all of the parameters that I
have available to me when I'm creating my classifier.
So, I can see that there's a whole lot that's going on here that I can tune.
There's something called the criterion, there's the splitter, there's max depth.
There's minimum number of samples in the split, minimum samples in the leaf, and
so on and so on.
So, these are all things that I can try tuning.
So, let me pick one of these.
We're going to look at the min's sample split.
We can see if by tuning the min_sample_split,
maybe, we can alleviate some of that overfitting that we
were seeing in the example that I just showed you.
So, here's what min_sample_split does.
Say, I have my decision tree.
Start out with a bunch of training examples,
then I start to split them into smaller sub-samples.
At some point, I have to figure out if I'm going to keep splitting any further.
So, for example, if I start out with 100 examples here,
then maybe I get 60 and 40.
And maybe, I get 40 and 20.
And then, maybe, this 20 turns into 15.
And, five and so on and so on.
So, the question is for each one of these bottom most sort of
layers in the tree whether I want to keep splitting it.
If it seems like that might be a good idea.
And, that's what min_samples_split governs is basically whether I
can keep splitting or not.
Whether there's enough samples that are available to me to continue to
split further.
So, the the default number for min-sample-split is two.
So, all of these nodes I can further split except for one of them.
So my question for you is which of these nodes
here are a few of your choices would I not be allowed to split any further?